you know I was gonna open this asking
what would your preferred mutant power
be except the whole point of mutant
powers is you don't get to pick what it
is so that's a pointless exercise hey
folks oh yeah
watching Dark Phoenix and then ranking
the x-men movies kind of put me in an
x-men head space and so I'm rolling with
it and I want to talk about what Marvel
Disney should be doing with x-men and no
I'm not gonna different specific
storylines I'm not gonna talk casting
I'm not gonna talk anything like that
it's just one very simple note x-men
should be a TV show not a film series
now obviously the first thing that
people are gonna come at me was is there
have been x-men TV shows unless for the
moment set aside like the 90s cartoon of
which I know everyone's like super
nostalgic for but I'm sorry it does not
hold up with the darn opening credit
music is amazing but show as a whole
hasn't aged well
but like I'm setting that aside and even
x-men evolution but like there have been
recent stuff there's Legion which is
great there's the gifted which I never
get around to seeing but I heard pretty
good things about but that's not what
I'm talking about because that's taking
elements things certain characters
certain bits of the x-men universe and
making TV short of that no I'm talking
the main series the main franchise the
characters people no I'm talking about
Wolverine Cyclops Jean Grey Nightcrawler
beast Colossus
Kitty Pryde Professor Xavier they should
be on television not in film and I yeah
I will explain why I think this is the
case so there are a number of things
that get lost when things get translated
from any medium into any other medium
and specifically we're talking about
comic book to film there are some
characters in some properties that take
a slight more of a hit than others
now some make the transition
surprisingly unscathed
and if we're even going with an x-men
Deadpool did pretty well but Deadpool is
an anomaly like within almost everything
but the thing is what honestly even the
x-men comics seem to have long forgotten
and a big part of why there was often a
bit of an issue with the film's at
looking at it as a series for me is that
the reason the comics at their best were
so good was because it wasn't nonstop
events at least it wasn't until about
the 90s or everything went to hell but
you look back at the 70s in the 80s the
kickoff of giant-size x-men basically up
and up through Liefeld's showing up and
introducing x-force and things starting
to go downhill I think most people would
actually tend to agree unless they have
serious not you know nostalgia blindness
going on that the 70s in the 80s were
the heyday for the x-men and if you
think that's my nostalgia blindness
talking I will point out I wasn't
reading comics in the 70s to the age I
wasn't even born in the 70s my comic
book reading would well in general and
with the extra minutes position was the
nineties it was gonna be nostalgic for
anything it would be for that but
nineties x-men friggin suck so I don't
think I'm talking not a nostalgia
blindness here but what was so good
about the x-men during that time period
is that not everything was a big
continuous events you had some you had
some big iconic stories many of which
have been ate from the films this was
the period of time that gave us Days of
Future past it gave us the dark Venus
Phoenix saga
it gave us God loves man kills all these
the Sentinels all these things that you
all all these movies have pulling their
cues from there from the 80s and from
the 70s but the reason those stories
worked and why not all of them worked in
film and why dark
especially never had a chance is that
because these are ensemble stories about
young people it's a soap opera more than
anything else and you need the downtime
you need the connective tissue you need
the relationships between the characters
and when all you do is cover big event
Titan type stuff which is basically what
always happens with movies then you're
missing that well I did my review of
Dark Phoenix I said they're missing a
movie in between apocalypse and this now
granted both apocalypse and Dark Phoenix
sucked but set that aside from him for a
second just look at them as narratives
at the end of apocalypse the team
assembled the team ahead like as we were
gonna see them in the next film
basically assemble for the very first
time Jean and Scott were just barely
starting out their relationship next
film starts and the T and the whole
thing is about the team breaking apart
that is no wait because we haven't seen
the team beat together but that makes
for a dull film or at least that seems
to be the mentality of the filmmakers
and now granted that was under Fox it is
Neal do their own thing but admittedly a
film where everything where the team at
least is jelly and coherent and
everything is fine between them for the
most part not a lot of people are gonna
make that film but that is the kind of
thing you do in a TV show you build up
to your big events for your finales but
leading into that you have the little of
interactions you build the relationships
between the characters you get to focus
on somebody other than Wolverine
mystique magneto or Professor Xavier cuz
12 films in that series Wow 10 if we
take Deadpool out of it cuz again he's
anomalous and honestly for as many other
characters just showed up in those films
those are the only ones who ever
mattered and that's a shame because the
strength of x-men is in the ensemble
it's the same reason that Star Trek
works so much better as a TV show and
that's not to say there have
good Star Trek films there have been but
the reason Star Trek works as a show by
design and by nature no matter what Star
Trek show we're talking about and no
matter which how you feel about which
ones are better than others the reason
it belongs on television is because you
need to be able to dedicate an hour an
episode to give us this relationship
this character this dynamic move this
thing over here and see what changes
just for the course of this one story
and then put it back to the status quo
you can do that with the TV show in a
way you can't do with film cuz film
demands size and scope especially with
summer blockbusters which pretty much
comic book you superhero movies almost
always are even if they're not released
in the summer there's still summer
blockbusters for all intents and
purposes and they won't do they'll try
and have those small moments worked in
here or there but it can't just be side
moments not if you're gonna do x-men
what makes x-men great at its best
you're gonna do that justice it can't
just be a little side moments it has to
be more than just rogue and Bobby Drake
having this little quirky little romance
going on you need to develop it you need
to have weight so that when you do
something like Dark Phoenix Jean losing
control matters because we care about
her we care about the relationships we
care about the damage being done to the
characters who we love but we never get
a chance to know these people in the
film not the not the ensemble cast just
a handful of the core members and again
you can get away with that and some of
those films are good I genuinely love
some of them but if you're truly gonna
represent x-men you need more space you
need more space and time then film
allows and this is not the only
franchise I think about that I think
this about like I think if they were
ever to have the idea to remake Harry
Potter it should be done as a TV show
because those films are also quite good
and I think excellent adaptations for
what they
are by and large but the one thing
that's missing the one thing that always
was the first thing to get cut
especially in the later films in that
franchise is the classroom stuff the
kind of stuff that you could have in a
TV series the kind of stuff that gives
it the feel of the school setting which
and people tend to forget this
x-men is also supposed to be a school
setting but we never get the feel of
that because nothing is ever happening
at the school there's never class
there's never the older people teaching
like maybe one scene but that's supposed
to be the setting that's supposed to be
the default the status quo we almost
never saw it in the films because they
were too busy off fighting magneto again
but you've got to have the downtime in
between otherwise the big moments don't
have the same weight and in x-men in the
comics those moments do have weight when
contrasted with the smaller moments and
I think this is something that to some
degree impacts almost every superheroes
franchise because all these characters
in the comics have smaller stories that
never make the film's because the films
are all about the big stories now how
much of a detriment that is to the
translation of the characters I think
that bears on a case-by-case basis some
of them I think get away with it fairly
well but x-men you really need the
downtime the small stories the small
moments though recovery like ice I if
you've never checked out the Council of
geeks podcast which you probably haven't
most people haven't but I covered every
issue of the nineties event executioner
song and it was terrible this was a 90's
x-men or event and it was awful but you
know what was great at the very end
there's a coda
there's an epilogue there's an unwinding
there was an issue of the comic after
this whole thing was done where the
characters just decompressed reconnected
talked to each other
tried to help each other through what
they'd just been through and be sure
everyone was okay and that was by far
the best thing to come out of that that
was a great issue and that and like an
entire issue devoted to it not a couple
pages the whole issue and that is the
kind of thing that x-men needs and is
missing and seeing the size of the scope
of some of the stuff that Disney and
Marvel are planning for Disney plus I
don't think I'm completely out of my
mind to think maybe they would actually
be willing to do this I mean they
probably won't x-men is a big enough
name they're gonna want to put it on the
big screen and it wouldn't be completely
out of the realm of possibility at this
point with Kevin if I'd you running
everything now for there to be the
proper crossover between the TV and
streaming shows and the movies that we
always wanted to never got so maybe it's
possible that there is a TV show that
has the students the day-to-day stuff
the interconnections and when they get
to something like Dark Phoenix they make
the movie maybe I'm a little more
skeptical about that idea I'd really
like you to just to find a home on TV
but I'd be open to that but we need the
space to have the quiet moments because
without them x-men is just bombast
and it gets real old real quick when
that's the case that's why I think x-men
should be on TV or streaming whatever at
this point what are your thoughts about
that whatever they are drops with me on
the comments let's talk about a whole
bunch of stuff to do as well because
like subscribe you can check out my
stuff help me out on patreon that is a
massive assistance but if you are not
able to do so just sharing this video
around
that helps quite a bit the almighty
algorithm has deemed it so but there are
things to click on buttons to press they
do things but you also don't have to I'd
appreciate it but at the end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]